hagamos otro problema de titulación
nuestro objetivo es encontrar la
concentración de una solución ácida de
20 mililitros de hcl y esta vez en lugar
de usar hidróxido de sodio usamos
hidróxido de bario durante la titulación
necesitamos 27.4 mililitros de una
solución
0.0 154 molar de hidróxido de bario para
neutralizar completamente el ácido
presente entonces empecemos con lo que
ya conocemos sabemos que la
concentración de hidróxido de bario
es 0.0 154 molar y también sabemos que
la polaridad es igual a los moles sobre
los litros así que 0.0 154 es igual a
los moles que será nuestra x entre los
litros 27.4 mililitros
0.0 274 litros
entonces si calculamos x x representa
los moles de hidróxido de bario usemos
la calculadora tenemos 0.01 54 x 0.02 74
esto es igual a 4.22 por 10 a la menos 4
entonces esto es igual a 0.000 422 moles
de hidróxido de bario muy bien ahora
escribamos la reacción de neutralización
el hidróxido de varios reacciona con hc
el más
hcl y producen h más
h menos forman h2o y el otro producto se
forma con varios 2 más
a dos más y cl - entonces ve a dos más y
cl - los cruzamos se forma de hacerle
dos cloruro de bario muy bien ahora
vamos a balancear la ecuación empecemos
con los claros del lado izquierdo
tenemos un átomo de cloro y del lado
derecho
tenemos dos así que pondremos un 2 aquí
ya tenemos dos claros en ambos lados
ahora vamos con los hidrógenos del lado
izquierdo
tenemos dos hidrógenos aquí y dos acá
tenemos cuatro hidrógenos del lado
izquierdo y del lado derecho sólo
tenemos dos hidrógenos así que
necesitamos poner un 2 aquí ya tenemos 4
hidrógenos del lado derecho y hemos
terminado lo demás ya está balanceado
ahora analicemos la relación molar entre
el hidróxido de bario y el h cl aquí
tenemos un 1 así que por cada molde
hidróxido de bario tenemos dos moles de
hcl y como ya sabemos cuántos moles
usamos de hidróxido de bario 0.000 422
el doble de esto es igual a los moles de
hcl entonces si multiplicamos este
número por 2 podemos saber cuántos moles
de hcl tenemos o también podemos usar
una proporción si hablamos de la
relación entre el hidróxido de bario y
él hcl la relación es 1 a 2 y sabemos
que el número de moles de hidróxido de
bario es de 0.000 422 nuestro objetivo
es saber cuántos moles de hcl estaban
presentes
en la solución inicial así que
necesitamos multiplicar 0.000 422 por 2
y nos queda x es igual a 0.00 0 844
moles de hc l finalmente calculemos la
concentración de la solución ácida y
empezamos con 20 mililitros de hcl
entonces 20 mililitros es igual a 0.0200
litros y como ya tenemos los moles y los
litros la concentración inicial de hcl
en la solución original es igual a 0.00
0 844 moles entre 0.0 200 litros usemos
la calculadora tenemos 0.000 844
entre 0.0 200 esto es igual a cero punto
cero 422 molar entonces la concentración
de hcl es igual a 0.04 22 molar esta es
la concentración inicial de nuestra
solución ácida veamos qué sucede si
tratamos de usar el atajo m v es igual a
emv que vimos en el vídeo anterior la
concentración de la base por el volumen
de la base es igual a la concentración
molar del ácido por el volumen del ácido
entonces para nuestra base sabemos que
la concentración es 0.0 154 molar y el
volumen de la base que usamos en la
titulación fue de 27.4 mililitros
para el ácido queremos encontrar la
concentración y el volumen era de 20.0
mililitros
entonces usemos la calculadora tenemos
cero punto cero 154 por 27.4 y eso entre
20 es igual a cero punto cero 211 usando
el atajo x es igual a cero punto cero
211 molar pero esta no es la respuesta
correcta es casi la mitad de la
concentración que obtuvimos por el
método largo entonces si quieren usar el
atajo para este problema necesitamos
multiplicar esto por 2 así obtenemos la
respuesta correcta
0.0 422 molar muchas veces los
estudiantes se confunden con esto de
multiplicar por 2 pero lo podemos
explicar analizando la reacción
balanceada
aunque
usar el atajo no es siempre la mejor
opción lo pueden usar si entienden cómo
funciona pero es mejor que para este
tipo de problemas en donde la relación
molar no es 1 a 1 lo resuelvan por el
método largo así podrán estar seguros de
que obtuvieron la respuesta correcta